ESTHER DUFLO: This course is about the
lives of the world's poor and the
problems that they face.
It's about both understanding why the
poor make the choices they make, what
are the constraints that they face in
their everyday life, and what all of
this tells us about what could
possibly be done to
improve those lives.
We will carve out all of the
aspects of people's lives.
ABHIJIT VINAYAK BANERJEE: We'll also
carve out the key existing research in
fighting poverty.
ESTHER DUFLO: Food, hunger, health,
education, how people decide about how
many children to have and how
to invest in those children.
It is hard to imagine a more
important problem.
SPEAKER 1: It's so cool to receive all
this information and points of view
from people and the students
from all over the world.
SPEAKER 2: I've learned that development
economics is for everybody
and anybody.
SPEAKER 3: It's just been fascinating
to hear the stories of people who
actually live and work in the areas that
we're talking about in many of
the studies.
SPEAKER 4: It's been really fascinating
for us because after
watching each lecture series, we are
able to walk outside and live what we
have learned.
We can ask questions and do our own
local research, like testing theories
and examples discussed.
The knowledge that we have gained will
make our service immensely more
impactful because we now have a deeper
understanding of global poverty.
SPEAKER 5: We thank you for having done
an incredible job making quality
education accessible in even the most
remote corners of the world.
ABHIJIT VINAYAK BANERJEE: I hope many
of you will take this course.
ESTHER DUFLO: And become
part of the solution.